[Musique]
bienvenue à la une de paris saclay tv le
quartier de l'école polytechnique un
quartier qui ne cesse de se
métamorphoser regardé autour de moi ces
commerces viennent tout juste d'ouvrir
et ce n'est que le début
à la une aussi ses pépinières qui
fleurait sur votre territoire avec un
tout nouveau lieu dédié aux entreprises
et aux start up
objectif les connecter à tous les
écosystèmes du cluster paris saclay
autres pépinières avec des plantes cette
fois ci des plaques locales qui vont
croître et se multiplier
la démarche et scientifique mais aussi
écologique respecter la faune et la
flore c'est aussi mettre en place des
liaisons douces pour les piétons pour
les cyclistes votre territoire innove
avec une piste ministre
on vous y emmène dans un instant nous
verrons aussi comment les entreprises et
les pme locales bénéficient les
opportunités liées aux clusters paris
saclay c'est tout l'enjeu du programme
achat pme grands groupes
retour sur un partenariat gagnant
gagnant et enfin un autre agenda c'est
l'été mais la rentrée se prépare
chaque année une centaine de projets
innovants émergent du cluster paris
saclay mais beaucoup se développe est
simple en or du territoire comment
inverser cette tendance paris saclay
lance un lieu dédié aux start-up et aux
entreprises
l'incubateur pépinière hôtel
d'entreprises les accueillera sept jours
sur sept est née connectera à tous les
écosystèmes du territoire la première
pierre vient d'être posée
antoine dussouy de le paix à paris
saclay vous en dit plus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on inaugurait l'incubateur
pépinière hôtel d'entreprises ici c'est
vraiment un lieu qui est dédié à
l'innovation et l'entrepreneuriat c'est
un lieu qui est pour les start up pour
les entrepreneurs et c'est un lieu qui
va les connecter à tout l'écosystème de
paris-saclay les grands pôles académique
institut polytechnique de paris
l'université paris saclay les grands
comptes comme comme edf comme servier
comme thales qui ont alors leur r&d à la
paris saclay ya plus de 100 startups qui
sortent chaque année des laboratoires
des des rangs des étudiants de paris
saclay et sont souvent des start up qui
sont liées à la technologie et à la
recherche du plateau et donc ses projets
d'entreprises ces innovations ont besoin
d'être connecté à ce cluster se pousse
ce grand pôle d'innovation pour
continuer à grandir faut créer des
emplois pour créer de la richesse avec
l'incubateur fait fini à l'hôtel
d'entreprises ont créé un lieu pour ces
projets vraiment au coeur du réacteur
ici et donc c'est un lieu qui va être
animée qui va proposer des services qui
va vraiment être un lieu partenariale
dans lequel on va chercher à impliquer
tout l'écosystème de paris saclay alors
il ya une équipe qui est en charge de ce
projet qui a été désignée après une
consultation après un concours et donc
c'est bouygues bâtiment ile-de-france
qui construit le bâtiment c'est la
caisse des dépôts et consignations la
banque des territoires avec des
partenaires privés qui est investisseurs
et puis côté exploitation
il ya donc stop and work et une finale
de regus et créative vallée est donc
cette équipe là
pour mission d'apporter les meilleurs
services pour les startups heures
vraiment des conditions de travail à des
standards internationaux de mener des
actions d'animation de mise en
visibilité de cet écosystème à l'échelle
internationale avec des partenariats un
peu avec les grands pôles d'innovation
dans le monde
c'est vraiment un projet qui est né sous
une belle étoile et qui est vraiment un
projet partenarial et qui va le rester
il est fait pour créer du lien pour
créer plus de visibilité pour créer plus
de partenariats entre l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'innovation et
l'entreprenariat de paris saclay
[Musique]
d'habitude quand il est question de
pépinières dans cette émission vous
parle plutôt de start up ou d'incubateur
mais là il s'agit d'une pépinière de
plants de plantes locales
elle est implantée dans la zac
versailles satory ouest et c'est un
projet innovant qui permet de récolter
et de semer des espèces pour préserver
des écosystèmes locaux
[Musique]
là on est à versailles donc sur le
plateau de satory et on est dans le
périmètre de la zone d'aménagement
concerté donc satory ouest qui a un
projet d'aménagement qui fait partie des
opérations qui sont portées par
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay il ya tout d'abord donc
l'ambition de créer un quartier qui est
à la pointe en termes de mobilité et au
niveau de l'industrie de la défense est
la deuxième grande ambition de ce projet
là qu'on poursuit c'est de créer un
quartier ville nature où il ya une forte
interpénétration donc de ces deux
éléments là donc l'urbain et le paysage
la biodiversité dans le cadre de cette
ambition de créer un quartier ville
nature l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris-saclay met en place
aujourd'hui donc une pépinière de
plantes locales
vous savez un projet qui est soutenu par
la région ile de france et qui qui se
fait en collaboration donc avec la ville
de versailles
la communauté d'agglomération versailles
grand parc et l'arboretum de chèvreloup
est l'objectif de cette pépinière de
plantes locales
c'est de reconstituer donc des milieux
qui existe aujourd'hui sur site dans les
futurs espaces publics du projet de
satory ouest en utilisant des plans qui
sont issus de graines qui sont récoltées
donc sur le site même
j'accompagne l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay pour la
constitution d'une pépinière de plantes
sauvages locales et donc ça débute pas
simplement la récolte de semences donc
des espèces sauvages sur site
donc cette année tout d'abord un plan de
sauvegarde donc des diagnostics des
inventaires pour voir quelles espèces ou
à les sauvegarder
et puis là on est au mois de juin donc
on est en plein dans la récolte donc il
va durer jusqu'à la fin de l'été parce
qu'il faut nettoyer les lots enlevait
des impuretés et avoir des semences à
ses frappes donc ça ça va à peu près
jusqu'à octobre
à l'automne on va semer en fait les
espèces sauvages c'est mieux de les
semer directement à l'automne pour
qu'ils lèvent au printemps prochain 2020
se joignent à peu près 60 espèces 64
espèces si mes souvenirs sont bons et
qui m'ont a inscrit dans ce plan de
sauvegarde
évidemment que c'est un intérêt puisque
ce sont des espèces qui sont adaptés
donc c'est des espèces sauvages locale
donc c'est à dire qu'elles sont elles
sont vraiment adaptées aux sols au
climat et donc elles sont aussi en
relation et toute la faune à la flore
c'est le support de vie de plein
d'autres espèces donc travailler avec
des espèces sauvages et bien
effectivement ça permet de maintenir la
diversité la biodiversité
l'environnement c'est l'une des grandes
priorités de votre territoire le pea
paris saclay choisi les liaisons douces
ces voies réservées aux cyclistes aux
piétons et elles permettent de respecter
la faune et la flore il n'y a pas de
lumière artificielle non cette piste et
les mini centre écoutez les explications
de michael tauriel c'est le directeur
des projets techniques de le paix à
paris ça pis
[Musique]
viens nous sommes sur la nouvelle route
départementale 128 qui vient d'ouvrir au
public et qui permet de désenclaver une
partie du quartier de l'école
polytechnique dans le cadre de l'appel à
projet ecocité ville de demain qui est
porté par l'état et la caisse des dépôts
le ps est engagé dans une action
innovante pour les liaisons douces
[Musique]
il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre une piste
le fluorescents fumi naissante qui
permet d'offrir aux usagers un nouveau
mode de transport sans éclairage
artificiel comme nous avons l'habitude
de le voir long de ce genre de piste
l'objectif est de se passer complètement
de lumière artificielle dans une zone
très naturelle du quartier l'école
polytechnique avec de force d'enjeux
environnementaux pour permettre à la
fois de répondre aux attentes des
usagers piétons et cycles mais également
de permettre le développement de la
biodiversité souhaité sur le
l'écoterritoire paris saclay
l'innovation est double et ce à deux
titres
premièrement nous avons mises en oeuvre
cette innovation avec l'aide de deux
entreprises eiffage route et colas qui
ont accepté de tester sur le territoire
paris saclay leurs produits qui
n'étaient pas encore commercialisé
deuxième innovation revient tout
simplement aux procédés de fabrication
de cette piste dans un premier temps
nous réalisons un enrobé tout à fait
traditionnelle puis dans un deuxième
temps nous venons semer des cailloux
fluorescents comme peut le faire un
agriculteur dans son champ puis dans une
troisième étape
nous venons compact et ses cailloux pour
venir en chasser les granulats dans
leurs robes et aux résultats nous
obtenons une nous voie partagée pour les
cycles et les piétons en répondant aux
usages attendus tout en permettant bien
évidemment de permettre à la faune à la
flore de continuer à se développer de
manière sereine
non
cette dynamique elle doit aussi
bénéficier aux petites entreprises aux
pme locales et c'est tout l'enjeu du
programme paris saclay achats pme grands
groupes
un partenariat gagnant gagnant comme
nous avons pu le constater à la terrasse
discovery +6
[Musique]
avant populaire val de france ses
partenaires de l'epa paris-saclay pacte
pme parce que d'abord c'est la première
banque des entrepreneurs c'est aussi la
première banque à avoir son siège sur
paris saclay la banque populaire val de
france c'est au travers du groupe bpce
est partenaire premium des jeux 2024
donc cela représente bien sûr de
nombreuses opportunités et la banque
populaire souhaite accompagner tous ses
partenaires fournisseurs clients et
contribue évidemment à l'essor
économique de biens victoire paris
saclay la banque populaire val de france
est une banque régionale donc l'économie
locale ça fait partie de notre adn
donc nous avons déjà 55 % nos
fournisseurs qui sont des fournisseurs
locaux
nous ce qu'on désire s'est développée du
partenariat avec les pme qu'elle nous
apporte l'innovation nous avons un
véritable défi à relever dans les années
à venir
nous devons faire évoluer nos usages nos
besoins seuls nous n'y parviendrons pas
nous avons besoin d'être accompagnés
nous avons besoin d'avoir une vision
extérieure d'experts qui puisse nous
interpeller et nous faire réfléchir sur
notre organisation et nos façons de
travailler
[Musique]
bonjour fils yves hasselin boutures
points comme on réalise donc des jardins
de biodiversité de bien-être avec de la
bienveillance en faisant travailler des
personnes qui sont en insertion
donc on a comme clients par exemple le
groupe thales le groupe suez le groupe
angie dans le cadre rencontre grands
comptes pme
on a rencontré donc le groupe suez et on
a pu présenter nos projets de
biodiversité de bien-être et de
bienveillance donc au groupe suez et on
a pu le réaliser l'aménagement de
lagence de bures sur yvette
cette manifestation c'est un véritable
levier pour nous pour accentuer
continuer à aller dans ce sens-là aller
encore plus avant et en avoir encore
plus de fournisseurs qui sont des
fournisseurs locaux et développer un
véritable partenariat avec eux
[Musique]
notre agenda présent c'est l'été vous
êtes peut-être en vacances évadez vous
avec l'office du tourisme destination
paris saclay vous propose un programme
de visites originales c'est gratuit
c'est sur inscription noter les dates le
mercredi 28 août et le 18 septembre
vous pouvez aussi préparer votre rentrée
et oui déjà
dès le 2 septembre prochain l'université
paris saclay repart sur les routes pour
la quatrième édition de webcom god sur
une vingtaine de dates l'université part
à la rencontre des étudiants et des
collègues des établissements afin de
leur parler du projet de répondre à
toutes les questions cette tournée dewe
gorode 4 s'achève le 15 octobre
enfin vous pouvez participer aux
journées portes ouvertes de l'école
polytechnique c'est le 12 octobre de 12h
à 18h30 c'est gratuit faut aller
s'inscrire sur le site si vous êtes
intéressé n'hésitez pas voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un très
bel été sur tv 78 et sur eps.fr a très
vite
[Musique]